اعلنت كتائب القسام ان مقاتليها اجهزوا من
المسافه صفر على عشره جنود اسرائيليين
بالاسلحه الرشاشه والقنابل اليدويه وذلك
شرق وشمال شرق مخيم البريدج وسط قطاع غزه
كما اعلنت القسام استهداف ست اليات
اسرائيليه منها دبابات ميركافا وناقله جند
في مخيم البريج وسط القطاع ومناطق بمدينه
خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه التي شهدت هي
الاخرى استهداف تجمعات لاليات وجنود
الاحتلال بقذائف
الهاو من جانبها اعلنت سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي ان
مقاتليها استهدفوا دبابه ميركافا
اسرائيليه بقذيفه ار بي جي شرق مخيم
البريج وسط قطاع غزه وقالت سرايا القدس ان
مقاتليها خاضوا اشتباكات ضاريه مع جنود
العدو بالاسلحه الرشاشه موقعين بهم اصابات
محققه في مناطق التقدم بمخيم البريج
ايضا